freunde herzlich willkommen zu meinem
neuen video zu meinem neuen format ein
tag essen wie in ich habe mir
vorgenommen ich möchte die landeskirchen
von verschiedenen ländern erkunden und
nicht nur erkunden ich will sie
erforschen wird sie versteht und dann
natürlich auch genießen und das haben
wir uns heute vorgenommen mit italien
also wirklich eine herzensangelegenheit
familie wichtig die vitalen und vor
allem die italienische küche deshalb
habe ich das auch nicht auf die leichte
schulter genommen ich habe recherchiert
und wir haben wirklich einen
authentischen italienischen tag
kulinarisch abgebildet und ganz wichtig
dabei ist wir werden nicht nur kochen
also das ist nicht viel ein tag
persönlich drei mal kochen sondern wir
werden auch essen gehen hauptsache
authentisch das ganze freue mich sehr
auf dieses format ich freue mich auf die
weiteren folgen die kommen werden und
euch jetzt erstmal viel spaß mit dem
video
[Musik]
was doch nicht machen so wir sind jetzt
angekommen im italienischen herz von
köln in der südstadt und jetzt gibt es
koalitionen also frühstück das
bestätigen italien tatsächlich einfach
aus einem kaffee oder einen cappuccino
und einem süßen hörnchen man ist nicht
viel zum frühstück in italien aber keine
sorge über den tag verteilt ist man sehr
viel und wo sollten wir das essen gehen
wenn ich in einer italienischen
authentischen kaffeebar der technik
[Musik]
ich liebe dich sagen ehrlich ist ja kein
geheimnis dass ich die italienische
esskultur liebe aber auch diese art zu
essen noch mal morgens für kleinigkeit
ist nicht so schwer ist einfach perfekt
ich habe jetzt ein cornetto mit aldi co
kg filter somit für sicher fühlt und
dazu gibt es ein kino das ist nämlich
ein ding italien man trinkt cappuccino
nicht nach 10 uhr das liegt daran dass
viele italiener sowie auch andere
europäer laktose-intoleranz eigentlich
und deshalb bringt man dass man morgens
ich
prinzipiell ist aber ein motiv des
italienischen frühstück dass es immer
klein schnell und süßes also es gibt
auch kekse werden ordentlich gegessen
oder diese abgepackt und was auch und
häufig sogar wenn man quasi auf dem weg
zur schule zur arbeit ist an der bar
direkt aber wir sitzen jetzt hier in
china und lassen ich bin auch schon sehr
gespannt hier bei dem format wo wir also
was wir auch alles einfach neu lernen
werden starten jetzt mit italien wir
kennen schon viel von italien aber genau
wohin geht die reise darauf freue ich
mich oder waffen auf mexiko den
philippinen ja alles so etwas und dann
auch wirklich mal dieses bewusstsein zu
erschaffen ein tag langen sich da auch
wirklich mal rein zu denken heißt ja und
auch für diese kultur zu genau freue
mich sehr auf dieses format ist das
macht für mich mir ich hoffe euch macht
spaß ich was für mich jesus denn dieses
konzept durch sagt ehrlich das ist ganz
anders als die französischen
produktionshaus hat so außen so eine
zucker kruste innen drin gefüllt mit
einem kopftor also mit pfirsich
marmelade ich sagte ich bin hier zuhause
auf werden eric hat ja die klassische
kombination espresso für schluck wasser
stecken immer so hingestellt 1 euro 50
die teile auch häufig ein euro also die
wissen auf jeden fall wie man lebt
[Musik]
genau so muss es sein gesagt fünf
minuten und angel stück jetzt dauert
eine weile und dann gehen wir
mittagessen so natürlich ist das so dass
wir heute so ein bisschen cherry picking
betreiben und uns die liebsten sachen
aus dem norden süden der mitte des
landes suchen und natürlich wenn jetzt
ihr italienische family ab oder so man
kennt ihr vielleicht auch die
essgewohnheiten anders aber seid euch
sicher alles was wir hier raus blicken
ist authentisch das ist das wichtigste
mittagessen man kann auch wirklich
hunger nach dem man nur dieses kleine
frühstück hatte wir gehen jetzt zu einem
alten bekannten nämlich zu in der nähe
und essen dort ganz klassische
italienische pizza kommt und mich hier
eine smokie barbecue
[Musik]
klar abseits von
klassischer
kommt nach dem backen
publikum her
[Musik]
napolitano mehr hotels der jetzt geht's
gar nicht wenig und haben gute zutaten
und liebe genau das sehen wir hier und
wir müssen jetzt einfach nur noch
probieren und so ihr haltet euch fest
das sind geräusche die man hören will
ich freue mich wirklich jetzt schon so
sehr auf die nächsten folgen von format
dieser authentizität zu genießen ist
jetzt bei italienischen relativ einfach
weil wir natürlich eine große kultur an
hier in deutschland aber ich freu mich
so krass auch so verrückte sachen zu
kochen an den ursprung zu gehen es ist
grenzer irgendwo an so einem experiment
gerade bei anderen volk 100 probiert
[Musik]
augen zu wo bist du ja alles heute muss
man nur essen wenn man es nach was macht
es wirklich außen grad jetzt hier bei
der italienischen diese das abendessen
will setzt dem ganzen die krone auf
leute die noch nie in italien waren
checken wäre ich gar nicht was sagen
gehen würde aber
dazu später mehr
[Musik]
mit so einer pizza auf fühlt man sich ja
wehren verbessert so das war unglaublich
lecker auch wirklich es ist jetzt
vielleicht wirkt vielleicht sollte würde
ich mir einfach machen und pizza essen
gehen so ein video aber für mich erfasst
das so gut zu dem geist vom
italienischen essen sondern gerade pizza
deshalb alles auf jeden fall eine gute
entscheidung und wie gesagt jetzt geht
es richtig los ich freue mich auch immer
wenn in einem der läden wo ich schon war
die ich gezeigt habe ich dann leute
treffe die wegen meiner video star sind
das ist immer cool und auch die
restaurants freuen sich eigentlich in
der regel immer darüber wenn wir da
waren das ist einfach geil ist einfach
nur aber nur positive annehmlichkeit
eben auch an zuschauer deshalb nicht
wenn du das siehst und liegen jetzt das
mal einkaufen würde ich sagen
[Musik]
so jetzt wird auch mal selbst hand
angelegt hier kochen drei gänge so wird
nämlich in italien häufig gegessen
manchmal sogar mittag und abendessen mit
rime secondo und terzo plateau also
wirklich drei gänge dabei geht es häufig
antipasti pasta und noch was süßes daran
merken auch dass italien eine nation ist
die sich wirklich das genießen von essen
auf die fahne geschrieben hat weil
glaube ich persönlich kenne kein land in
dem so viele mahlzeiten oder gänge über
den tag eingenommen werden wir haben ja
die frischen und besten zutaten frische
pasta passat zitronen denn wir machen
wie gesagt als erstes spaghetti butter
meesker und danach gallopin al limone
also ihr seht vielleicht was das ganze
ist eine sache es noch ganz wichtig es
gibt keine perfekten rezept angaben oder
so es geht mehr darum den respekt für
die italienische küche zu zahlen und
deshalb ist viel mit schön gefilmten und
so keine gramm milliliter angaben wir
kochen einfach wir fangen an mit dem
skalpell limone welcher auch überhaupt
nicht schwer sind genauso wie die
spaghetti wir brauchen einfach nur
zitronen gewonnen sind zitronen etwas
wein etwas mehr etwas zeit etwas pfeffer
und schnitzel kalbsschnitzel los geht's
[Musik]
eine zitrone schneiden wir in feine
scheiben und die andere pressen wir aus
sind übrigens natürlich sizilianische
zitronen unbehandelter naturbelassen und
wenn ihr das gemacht habt könnt ihr euch
auch schon ein schnitzel schnappen vom
kalb sind hätten wir einfach so mit dem
handballen jetzt erstmal ein bisschen
platt drücken und irgendwie mit einem
hammer dran wir müssen einfach so schön
flach machen so wie hier butter reihen
und dann beraten wir das ganze auch
schon an
[Musik]
das bedeutet den italienischen sport für
mich sehr viel also vor ihm sehr viel
weil ich liebe sie es ist einer meiner
lieblings küchen und für mich ist es
sehr nah mit dem land verknüpft mit der
landschaft sowie halt auch diese ganzen
geilen produkte wachsen wo das alles
herkommt so wohl auch die menschen sind
die so diese passion haben und sich so
etwas auszudenken so jedes einzelne
italienische gericht hat janis
unglaubliche geschichte und so
dementsprechend ist auf jeden fall eine
der ganz großen küchen für mich und
freue mich auch dass wir damit starten
können bedeutet wir auf jeden fall
wirklich einiges so parallel machen wir
es auch die nudeln fertig und das ist
auch so denkt eigentlich jede
italienische hausfrau muss eigentlich
drauf haben fünf sachen gleichzeitig zu
kochen so wenn sie traditionell
italienisch kochen möchte und der
aufgabe stelle ich mich jetzt deshalb
rede ich nicht so viel und ihr seht
einfach dabei zu
[Musik]
man sieht waren auf jeden fall ist ja
eigentlich ist eine belastung für farbe
bekommen
[Musik]
ein bisschen davon konnten überhaupt ein
bisschen dass wir in der pfanne
[Musik]
sondern könnte auch essen aber nicht mit
dem hier sondern passt da wird natürlich
nur mit der gabel gegessen eine
wunderschöne super simple pasta sehr
kräftige soßen pikant dieser tag heute
fühlt sich ein stück weit eigentlich
sogar normal oder ja und nein also ich
zelebriere halt das des öfteren schon
die italienische küche aber in dem maß
und so bewusst selten und deshalb finde
ich es eigentlich echt gerade kein
problem mir
dieser day haben wirklich kraft auch die
peperoncini haben wirklich gute schärfe
so mag ich sehr sehr gerne teilt kapern
familien wird dem ganzen cremige note
gelungener premiere glück wartet schon
unseres zekorn nur auf uns nämlich da
hinten im ofen und den lassen wir jetzt
so dann kommen wir jetzt auch zur scalo
pina allem ohne darauf freue ich mich
sehr weniger verbreitet das gericht in
deutschland genauso wie eigentlich die
meisten sachen die wir gegessen heute
sehen wir
das sehr schön zart und die zitronen
note kannst du dir vorstellen immer
sonst so zu essen ja so zu kochen nein
also weiße weil das ist halt so die
esskultur beruht halt auf liebe zum
essen so ist halt wirklich so ist so oft
ist so viel ist so frisch ist so gut so
dass nicht mal genau wir hätten nämlich
eigentlich mittags premiere morgen genau
es gibt dann auch quasi das frühstück
gibt es einen nach frühstück dann gibt
es die mehr ende also ein snack
zwischendurch haben es ein bisschen
runter gebrochen aber das ist glaube ich
der alltag so wie es in vielen
italienischen familien tagtäglich
aussieht und das wollen wir jetzt bilden
kurz antwort zu essen ja so kochen wein
kommt aber noch eine kleinigkeit und
dann sehen wir es auch schon zur
abmoderation das war's mit dem konto
jetzt vom klassischerweise die deutsche
also quasi ein kleiner snack hinterher
das kann sein panna cotta das kann seit
therapie zu aber häufig ist es auch
einfach obst und wir haben hier eine
schöne honigmelone geholt ist merke ich
jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen darüber
nachdenken wie das eigentlich heute so
viel mit war wie das gewirkt hat wie
geil das war die scheiße das war versuch
mal die altkreise in einem satz zu
beschreiben italiener haben genießen
verstanden
ist so das ist einfach pure genuss das
ist zeitintensiv können mir vorstellen
dass viele leute die so nice to five
arbeiten das gar nicht hinbekommen
könnten in diesem maße aber man nimmt
sich dort die zeit einfach und das ist
richtig weil daraus spricht halt eben
diese liebe zum essen ich habe es sehr
genossen heute ich bleibe dabei dass die
italienische küche eine meiner top drei
top 20 auch dieses lieblings küche ist
aber ich freue mich umso mehr auf die
verschiedenen küchen die wir in diesem
format erkunden werden und gerade auch
auf die exoten schreibt wirklich gerne
mal in die kommentare wir euch das
format gefallen hat wenn ihr
verbesserungsvorschläge ab das uns auch
wissen und
abonniert werden den kanal das habe ich
ganz lange nicht gesagt es würde mich
sehr freuen